today i'm going to show you the number
one
perfect remedy
for a condition called
keratosis
polaris
it's also known as chicken skin or
strawberry skin
because it gives you this kind of like a
goose like appearance these little bumps
on the back of your arm it could be on
the thigh it could be on the face but
there's these little bumps that are red
and a little bit swollen and we're going
to talk about the potential mechanism of
what's behind that and then what to do
about it there's a really awesome remedy
for this that you need to be aware of
over 50 of the population has this
condition it's not dangerous
it's not acne
but it can give you a little clue on
what's going on on the inside the body i
like to use symptoms especially
superficial things on the body to kind
of pull the string to see what's behind
it versus just treating a symptom and
then the underlying cause is now
camouflaged and now you're dependent on
this treatment that keeps treating the
symptom over and over and over so if you
understand the mechanism you can get rid
of the cause
then it goes away so what do they know
about keratosis polaris they know it's
an excessive amount of keratin growing
on the surface of your skin
primarily in the area of your follicles
and there's these little plugs that
become swollen and red and you'll see
them as tiny little red dots
most commonly in the back of the arm
right here now a lot of teenagers have
this i remember i had it growing up i
had no idea what it was you know at
first i thought it was acne but it's not
acne so i'm going to go through the kind
of the mechanism of what's behind this
and then you can kind of isolate
where your problem could be coming from
because there's multiple
things that can trigger this condition
so the first thing is a vitamin a
deficiency okay when you're deficient in
vitamin a you can have a lot of skin
issues you can get acne and you may
think well you know i'm eating enough
carrots so i'm getting enough vitamin a
so i should be fine but carrots don't
give you the active form of vitamin a
which is retinol you get beta-carotene
it has to be converted into retinol at a
very small percentage so the best source
of vitamin a is from things like beef
liver
fish
eggs
butter
and so it's a fat soluble vitamin that
also helps you see in the dark so if
you're consuming those foods you also
may be deficient because of another
reason in order to
absorb vitamin a especially the active
form you need a good liver so if there's
a problem with your liver let's say you
have a fatty liver or you had your
gallbladder removed or you have a
gallbladder problem or for some reason
you have this gut issue that you might
be breaking down vitamin a but further
down in the digestive tract you can't
pull it in it's called malabsorption and
it also could be that you
decided to become a vegan and you no
longer consume animal products so you're
trying to get your vitamin a from
vegetable sources and good luck on that
or it could be that you went on a low
fat diet and you just don't consume
enough of the foods that have vitamin a
all right another factor is androgens on
the skin okay that's a male hormone but
women have it as well and there has been
a relationship between
higher levels of androgen in females and
getting this keratosis polaris
especially if they have a condition
called polycystic ovarian syndrome
where the ovaries are producing too much
androgen that's a male hormone and
that's affecting the skin also hair loss
and other problems and one common cause
of that
would be high levels of insulin in the
blood they call that hyperinsulinemia
and so this hyper too much insulin in
the blood problem can not just trigger
androgens to cause this problem but can
directly affect your skin in a very
negative way there are so many different
problems that occur when your insulin is
too high especially with the skin i mean
you can get skin tags you can get rough
old skin
but not just on the skin but it happens
on the internal part of your body too
inside your arteries so there's a lot of
issues with that and so we have to
recognize this
high level of insulin connection too and
what can cause that of course the things
that you may already know consuming a
high carb diet eating too frequently
doing a lot of snacks but there's some
other things that can also increase
insulin like high levels of stress that
can increase cortisol which then can
increase insulin and that is why
people that go through emotional stress
or chronic stress
tend to have this keratosis polaris and
also there's a higher risk of people
that are obese that have metabolic
syndrome that have this as well because
of the insulin factor and there's also
one other really interesting
trigger for high insulin and that is
consuming a lot of omega-6 fats
corn oil soy oil canola oil it's in all
the restaurant foods fast foods it's in
a lot of foods that you probably already
eat right now
not only is it very inflammatory but it
can actually raise your
insulin it's fascinating because omega-6
fatty acids are essential fatty acids
and that is supposed to
prevent or fix this problem but what
people don't know is you have to have
the right ratios of omega-6 to omega-3
the average person is like way way too
high in omega-6 and way too low in
omega-3 which is the opposite it's like
anti-inflammatory so they don't make
this distinction
in a lot of the data when you read about
this condition they just give you the
data oh you just need to have a
essential fatty acids to help your skin
and they don't tell you the very
important point of
the ratios the ratios are key you don't
want a high ratio of a lot of six to
omega-3 fatty acids and keratosis
polaris has a bit of inflammation in it
too and so we don't want anything in our
bodies that are creating more
inflammation now the last point that
triggers
this condition
is estrogen dominance and this is why
you see people who take birth control
pills all of a sudden get these little
bumps in the back of their arm or their
legs or when a female becomes pregnant
she may also develop that condition as
well so estrogen can play a factor
and cause this problem so what is the
perfect remedy okay well it would be
something that combines all of these
factors in one thing okay
and that thing is you ready for this
cod liver oil not regular fish oil but
cod liver oil why
because cow liver oil combines
omega-3 fatty acids okay which will
automatically help you lower the omega-6
ratios
number two it's really good for your
skin
three it's anti-inflammatory
four it helps your blood sugars which
means it helps
reduce
insulin
and another thing about color oil is it
has vitamin a it's one of the best
sources of vitamin a which will help
create a normal amount of keratin
on the skin
and on top of that there's a bonus about
collard oil it has vitamin d in it it's
a good source of vitamin d
which is great for the skin vitamin d
helps not only lower insulin but it
helps reduce inflammation
for those of you that don't like the the
cod liver burps you can get them in a
capsule i'll put a link down below for
more information on that but somehow you
need to find a high quality cod liver
oil that you can use to reverse this
condition and also with your diet make
sure you correct some of these
imbalances that we talked about like
really making sure you don't have all
this omega-6
fats in your diet make sure you go on a
low-carb diet try like heck to manage
your stress level and do things to
improve your liver but start doing cod
liver oil and you're going to notice
within two to three weeks
it'll start to fade it'll start to get
better and better and better now if you
haven't seen my video on the benefits of
cod live oil because there's a lot of
other benefits i put it right here check
it out